you're very uh private with like your
personal life and you're pretty open
right I'm way too open and my husband is
way too open I'm like we're not going to
talk about everything next time because
yeah what has been shown is our entire
sex life great hey but that's not a
problem
congratulations congratulations no one
has ever said that yeah well not
everybody's having that life right now
um so you're you're back to you so
you're you're very private about it
though right you're like so here's the
thing I'm not private I have never been
private of my relationship I love to
flun my mens I love it yeah because I
usually get them Hot smart and Rich oh
yeah all
right I mean yeah I love it yeah you
know women wear jewelry and we usually
have you are what you're extended of the
person next to you right yeah this is
why I tell guys I'm like I don't know
why they are so afraid of getting
married you literally getting a buildin
coner your wife is like 24 hours coner
no opposite no no he's my coner well for
you and your relationship but most women
they're the one who taking care of their
wife what to wear what to eat married
men have a better life divor yeah than
single men no I'm with
[Music]
you
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home